[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
the doctor body-shaming here's the hey
man your liver is failing you don't have
the healthy liver I'm like dude don't
body shaming okay this is a little liver
of the white system a lesbian feelings
I think there's a name for people who
are not transgender it's cisgendered
anyone who's not everyone here unless
you're transgendered is cisgendered that
crazy did you imagine if everybody who
had an age for people who weren't then
let me Kate off okay yeah
since tonight it's this race this agent
would take forever to tell anyone your
douchebag got this covered every
minority who thinks that they have to
have an n-word the jealous of black
people I mean what do they get a word on
the word - it wasn't your terrible [ __ ]
just be happy that that people care
about you they don't do terrible [ __ ] -
you know like no one's ever like to a
raise awareness for little people call
Asian people visions okay it's just a
wishing recall you know that one calling
that's not a minute oxidant - let's say
a lot of people who are anti PC with a
PC culture is ruining America they want
to be able to say hurtful words like we
charge or [ __ ] but then they get
really offended when you call them
racist or sexist look who's a little
[ __ ] now sorry I try to describe the
part of your personality no optional
change
[Music]
down I don't understand love the Sun
Shabazz on TV you get on CBS a [ __ ]
and you suspect women but you can't get
on TV insane [ __ ] and this is back
through I think women deserve the same
protection we get on the street drop
something [ __ ] I'll be very offended
so this suppose like you drop your [ __ ]
okay well we'll just consider an answer
people are like immigrants are the words
ban immigrants I've been seeing this
video games you're terrible people
so let's stop smoking weed open the
apartment this is my country people
think Mexicans are destroying America I
don't think Mexicans are destroying
grandpa
either give me on how hilarious that
they did destroy America there lies the
right down by people helping them think
the Nazis never figured this out let's
go to America other dishes the people
with less money than me what about the
people at Verizon yes they have money
without the money that's who's taking my
money and they don't have I don't have
it
let's see I hate hate my ex my ex is a
[ __ ] this my impression of my ex
talking to my friends my ex talking to
my friend yeah you guys are talking
about something great in general and
relatable so why don't I contribute with
something very specific that we happen
to need me a person you've never been
going through something boring I'll
never go through that's all talk about
how that made me feel
what I make it look good I'll be around
for at least two more weeks when X says
she still thinks about me every day
which makes me happy because I'm a loser
and then water to waste your time why
are you thinking about the loser you
loser
looks like I'm plenty the break-up I'm
so talking about you two years later in
the land that some people some people
say they see the glass half full other
people see the glass half empty
nothing is both you guys are staring at
a cup of water weight being [ __ ] by
corporations I'm sorry no water
[Applause]